go go go go go go go 1 2 3 yes
[Music]
4 he's about to do it he's about to do
it 5 good morning Jay MERS today we have
a lot of stuff to do isn't that right -
where's Tower of llama wait a minute
you're again banked spin Babita maybe
they just went over here Sven this is
bad where could they have gone
so I thinked what about the ranch
oh no it's not working at the ranch let
me ask what about my slaves I mean my
employees they're all God they're all
why Wow ding-ding-ding this is so sad
not even counsel of what their sheep
it's with me I have no one but counsel
of disproportionate beat a Council of
beat what should I do
all my friends left me
[Music]
welcome home on welcome home I read
while Homer read one Roman bloke
borrowed money I'm a sacrifice beats to
you
but isn't that cannibalism work one
woman like one woman wrote for Homer
read one world one well very well I will
not question the Council of beat I will
make the greater speed farm this world
has ever seen
I'll do whatever it takes to get my
friends back if there's one thing I'm
good at in life is making beats how do I
hear a cat in my machinery oh my god
you're not elaborate that I don't even
know who you are get out of my sight I'm
so lonely I'm so lonely I have no one
but me and my beets grow my children
grow and bring back my Sven
okay while I'm making the beets let me
show you guys
I've been busy filling up the ceiling
and I'm done most of the walls and then
I'm I looked up a tutorial and you can
apparently make like you can apparently
make
self storing hoppers so if you name any
items anything and you just put anything
else and put a comp rater
and some other wiring deeply dabbling
you put them in here they start blip
blop blip blop blip blop it goes here
blip blop blip blop blip blop blip up
and it goes here clip-clop clip-clop
clip-clop a peg say i'll probably set
that up in the future my beats my lovely
beats my only friends the only ones I
will never leave me Oh
let's watch it look at that look how
many beats I'm getting well get out
there they are my beat grow why am I not
getting beats I'm so sorry guys I'm so
sorry I'll never do that again
oh my god that cat is so annoying listen
I don't want you you're adopted
seriously what are you even oh you're
old dirty you're dirty cat you're smelly
dirty old Kane yeah go through that's
right see if I care
oh god I'm so sad everyone leaves me why
why Wow
it's just me and my beat my be truth hey
can I fish beat no my children my sweet
children I must pay the toll to the
beetroot cancel more beat more beat more
beautiful it begins with B truth and it
ends with beetroot my father was a
beetroot surprisingly not the weirdest
thing I've said they're all playing
Minecraft people have been saying I have
tick speed on too quickly
these people clearly know nothing about
growing beets so I've been thinking
about re I know this is very this is
extremely controversial and I know a lot
of people are gonna say a lot of things
about it but I'm thinking about moving
iqi to the tip tip I'm thinking about
moving IKEA tower just cuz its kind of
you can't really see its beauty from up
close
I'm thinking about putting IKEA tower on
top of there isn't that kind of awesome
and I want to build it out of like
mainly wool material so I want to try
and build what I've been wanting to do
for a long time but I finally found how
to do it which is an automatic rule of
making farm one of the greatest joys in
Minecraft
it's killing animals for no reason you
my sweet child you're coming with me oh
my god it goes through his brain follow
me my children yes you may freak on the
way I'll guess you already are you know
what I'll just take their child instead
that feels more evil I like that look at
him they've already forgot about you
little Jimmy that's right
your name is mr. beast that's right
you're named after mr. B's follow me
little Jim Papa poops gonna take good
care of you don't worry nothing bad will
happen to you Jim my track record is
impeccable Jim gee I wonder why people I
wonder why everyone ran away from me
let's try to move those tiny little legs
those tiny tender their legs
yeah what is wrong with his face
don't ever do that again are you looking
for your mom you don't have a mom
your mom less okay follow me Jim it's
gonna be okay trust me I know you're
scared but they're good they're a good
Council come in
you will not trespass the holy ground of
your forefathers Jim I'm sorry but you
have note you have no - oh my god
that's why they never who left the
church they threw it physically Oh cows
I bring with me my greatest friend in
life my companion as requested
Gregoire woman right one woman right one
woman what do you want me to do name it
well I alerted an ape I named him Jim
after my favorite YouTube but one woman
read one woman
read one woman one woman feed it okay
easy
anything for Council of beat well what's
that word for woman pleasure in
potential repeat please woman okay okay
okay I will pleasure stay here Jim Oh
God oh no this is Jim's first time I bet
he's so scared Jim listen to me it's
gonna be okay just get in the boat there
you go
my god he's already enticing me oh this
is too perfect okay so you guys taught
me how to make them quicker you just
wait there you go oh god oh no that's
too fast even know it's that way
Oh God forgive me for what I'm about to
do what's happening what happened
Oh with its a back massage my lord it's
a back massage I'm just trying to keep
it family friendly whoa hey Jen look at
me look at me don't be afraid
why is it so funny
don't look at me Jim
oh god don't look at me lookie
please cancel work one woman it's enough
with one woman
place lemmy's work one room I know why
cancel of beat why I just wanted a
friend council a beat I just wanted one
friend to not leave me alone
work work work what's that click the
button this one oh my god a friend
Thank You Council of beat I knew you
were good after all all right let me
name name and flip-flop my new best
friend in life
Oh God we can swim together he's like a
fish dog can dolphins go in boats
now this top-10 at questions science has
an answer come on flip-flop get in the
boat
get in the boat where you belong
flip-flop come on don't be such a
sourpuss surely he can get him boat whoa
that's right getting a boat come on son
Oh sad he can't get in boat dolphin will
never experience joy oh my god he jumped
straight in yes
we're gonna have the best time you and I
flip blood oh my god does that mean he
can go okay you can get out of there
someone I hit you yes flip-flop we're
gonna have so much fun
what if we can re configure this to loop
around going in water flick pop will go
forever roller coaster would you like
that flip-flop say no if you don't want
that I think that's a yes I think it's
trying to say yes oh my god oh my god
yes
flip flop flip flop can you hear me do
you speak English I don't know I don't
think it speaks English yes yes go oh my
god yes don't block don't block him it
works it work flipy love you can jump
high now his dream come true of jumping
so high Wow he loves it jump over me
flip-flop Wow again Wow the rain is
keeping in my life don't worry about it
I'm gonna build you the greatest jumper
of all time flood blood all right we
need to stop this you could you can
you're gonna make me one rich man flip
lot people are gonna come all over the
world to see you perform
let me just build this a little banner
okay let's try this
oh my god that is perfect
this is going to be the greatest slime
roller coaster the world has ever seen
let's go are you kidding me yes no yes
yes oh my god yes and then again close
enough okay
I just realized I think redstone might
be do these work in water no they don't
I would have been so cool if they do I
wonder if there's a way to do it like
this is pretty cool right have you guys
ever done something so stupid well you
have to finish it no matter what
[Music]
me neither
if this thing works then I have
successfully changed the dolphin
roller-coaster business forever
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the world's first working dolphin roller
coaster I just heard myself say it was
ever done this all right let me
demonstrate it's pretty cool I'm not
gonna lie Oh what happened it doesn't
matter
[Music]
there you go one floor to floor this
took my soul no what happened I think it
was my fault okay they should work it
out yeah look you need a certain amount
of speed there you go and here it comes
the best part so it goes in the water
because dolphin needs to touch water
otherwise they drown and then it
continues oh my god and then it goes
back up and back in again
dolphin rollercoaster flip-flop my sweet
child
I'm starting to think maybe dolphins and
roller coaster don't actually match at
all there it is there it is there it is
this is the one it's fine it's fine he
can do it again go go go go go go go 1 2
3 yes
[Music]
4 he's about to do it he's about to do
it 5 flip-flop Danny go all the way and
Beyond flip flop flip flop the world's
first dolphin roller coaster everyone
they said it wasn't possible but I did
it now let's find more dolphins it's
beautiful
[Music]
it's absolutely beautiful God come on
flip-flop
we must tell Council of beetroot they're
gonna be so happy I'm just trying to
walk my dolphin what's the problem here
and I did as you commanded I built them
come from the coast are you pleased but
one woman like my old man like one woman
like one Roma
thank you your blessing mean more than
anything counselor beetroot
well one woman well for woman Gregoire
woman sacrifice flip-flop but he's my
best friend
sorry flip-flop but he must be done
don't look at me don't look at me
Oh God no I don't care
flip-flop is my new best friend
I will never sacrifice him oh god
they're so angry what are we doing
Oh No
[Music]
hurry up and escape flip-flop
but it's this
Oh God Oh
hello
was there
is it
faking all right gamers I'm gonna end
that episode there if you enjoyed smash
light check out Burt and I see you
gamers next time bro finger